Graham: Look at that silver fox.
So distinguished,
so sophisticated.
Wow!
But what if I told you
that this guy was a millennial?
It's true,
just barely.
According to Joe,
he started going gray when he was 16.
By 22, he was pretty much totally gray.
Why does that happen?
And why does hair turn
gray in the first place?
There's something about a silver fox,
if you can pull it off.
When I got rid of my gray hair,
I wanted a natural look.
Graham: But many people
hate the idea of going gray.
There's an entire industry
built around fighting it.
It's like you took off 10 years.
And in just five minutes.
Man: Just For Men.
She'll love the way you look.
Graham: So why does it happen?
The process of hair
changing from darker color
to white or gray with age
is mainly due to genetics.
It can be inherited from either parent.
The color of our hair is determined
by the form of hair pigment that we have.
The pigment is actually
produced along the hair shaft,
and there are two main
forms of hair pigment.
There's eumelanin
and pheomelanin.
Eumelanin is what we see in brunettes
and darker-haired people,
and pheomelanin is what we see in blonds
and redheads.
The cells in our hair bulb
produce a little bit of hydrogen peroxide,
which is a metabolic byproduct,
and typically there's an
enzyme called catalase
that breaks this down to water and oxygen.
But as we age, there's
declining levels of catalase,
and this allows the build-up
of hydrogen peroxide
in the hair bulb, which damages
and destroys the melanocytes,
or the pigment producing
cells, of our hair.
So I wanted you to take a look
at my colleague Joe here.
Joe is technically a millennial.
He started to go gray when he was 16,
and by 22, it was pretty
much gray all over.
What happened to Joe?
Jennifer: So when individuals
gray early in life
before the age of 20,
it's called premature graying,
and this is due to genes.
And we know there's one gene in particular
that's been targeted called
interferon regulatory factor 4,
which is important in regulating
and producing melanin in the hair.
Joe was lucky enough to inherit some genes
that predisposed him to developing
gray hair early in life.
Obviously, Joe has gray hair on his head.
When you go gray on your head,
does the hair on the
other parts of your body
go gray as well?
No, no, Joe, Joe!
We can picture it.
Jennifer: So you can grow gray
hair anywhere on your body.
Wherever you have hair,
the hair is susceptible
to oxidative damage
and eventually going gray.
Graham: So the main cause
of going gray is genetics,
but what role can stress play?
After all, Obama didn't look like this
when he showed up at the White House.
Jennifer: So it's controversial
the role that stress has in hair graying.
We know that stress
creates oxidative damage
in the body,
and it's been linked to a lot
of premature-aging syndromes.
So it's thought that the stress,
that stress causes oxidative damage,
which may cause damage to the melanocytes
and may cause us to grow gray earlier.
We know that smokers tend to go gray
moreso than the general population,
and again it's felt that
it's probably due to
the oxidative damage that smoke causes
and how it affects the
pigment-producing cells in the hair.
I think eating a well-balanced diet,
so you make sure
that you don't develop any
nutritional deficiencies,
that's another thing that can be done.
And modulating your stress.
That's another thing
you have control over,
which over time can cause oxidative damage
and, again, make you prone to
potentially more gray hair.